there's a winner from the war in Ukraine
it's Qatar wait Qatar the tiny desert
country in the Persian Gulf that kind of
looks like a thumb hear me out the first
thing you need to know is that Russia
actually provides Europe with a ton of
energy through natural gas they've got
these huge pipelines that feed Europe
with natural gas oh I see where this is
going let me guess something something
sanctions you'll see but yes sanctions
Europe sanctioned Russia's economy and
in retaliation Russia cut off the gas
that it was sending into Europe the gas
that they used to heat their homes and
cook their food and like stay warm
during the winter and like run their
factories oh so Europe can't get its gas
from Russia anymore because of the
economic War so they're turning to Qatar
Bingo guitar has tons of natural gas and
now Europe is knocking at their door
being like hey we need natural gas they
don't have any pipelines that they can
just like flip on for Europe but over
the next few years they are going to
dramatically ramp up their natural gas
production to meet all this demand in
Europe whoa this is sounding like big
money for guitar huge money for Qatar it
also means a lot more influence